after all this is done and after the
nurses wore the garbage bags and after
everybody dies there's people gonna be
like singing that Lee Greenwood song
it's gonna be so far I'm proud to be an
American where at least I know I'm free
[Music]
great ah but that's the thing the
economy Trump says we're gonna have the
church is full by Easter Nicole if that
happens our call to Easter Massacre
start killing everybody on Easter
you know doctors say that this thing is
[ __ ] unpredictable in every
imaginable way you don't know how it
really affects you you'd be healthy and
drop dead you can be unhealthy and it
could be okay
you could be old it could be young it
doesn't you know they don't know
anything about it they don't truly have
a real understanding of this it's it's
all pretty much based on averages and
numbers and Chinese full of [ __ ] I mean
some so Rogan sent me an article the
other night which I don't know if it's
making the rounds Ben's gonna pull it up
where it says China's missing 21 million
you cellphone users they just went
offline hmm yeah it was in Bloomberg if
you know anything about China you know
that their cell phones are way to track
the population so you know cell phone is
pretty important in that country
especially of that government they want
you to have a phone they want you to
have a phone so they could find out what
the [ __ ] you're up to
so China mobile subscriptions fell by
more than eight million over January and
February data on the company's website
show China Unicom Hong Kong subscribers
fell by seven point eight million in
this period well china telecom corp has
lost 5.6 million users last month what
are we saying does this mean that the
death totals are much higher and that
they're running 24-hour crematoriums and
they are just burning bodies I don't
know I'm asking a question I'm saying
does this mean that the death total is
so much higher so much
now they're like Spain has more deaths
in China it's like wait what really
that's what they're saying look it up
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense or maybe
not more deaths but more cases what are
they saying
um so on the Bordeaux meter we have a
t-1000 in China and 57,000 in Spain
that's oh but that's yeah by like 2000
more yeah 1500 more no way dude I call
bluff yes no way China's but China's
Juke in those number China I know what
you did you you're good you China is
taking people and throwing them in a
furnace by the way you know where their
cases went out cuz if you go report a
case they go oh thanks hold on you know
when you're going to a doctor and they
sit you on the little thing and they go
they take your blood pressure go hold on
the doctors gonna come in it and being
in a minute if you complain of kovat
symptoms they to Chinese guy goes yeah
hold on a dr. B in a minute and then the
military comes in to shoot you in the
face I mean there's no way I mean like
if you're reporting those symptoms right
now they are not even listening they're
not hearing that ain't nobody got time
for that they're gonna put the gun in
your throat yeah they're gonna pretend
this is some thermometers you can look
at it's gonna be a gun they're done
Chinese done with this [ __ ] they're like
we're done with coronavirus next they
don't give a [ __ ] hey guys gotta be
honest with you it may be it's not the
worst attitude I don't know I don't know
I flippity-flop I'm on the fence here
you know we cannot we cannot sit in our
homes for six months I know some people
think we can't save no idea the economy
works and they're masturbating all day
they think this is fun they're eating
pancakes just whacking it and they're
like this is great what's everyone's
problem some of us like to get out and
do something does it mean do it tomorrow
we're not going there but I'm saying
eventually we need to kind of we need to
get out we you know we can't just have
[ __ ] we can't all be sitting there
waiting for martial law forever mm-hmm
you know looking out the windows going
wonder the tanks gonna roll down the
street